thank you all for coming for the BAFTA
original music session we have the
nominees of the nominated for Sicario
and the revenant Johanna Hanson and
Alvin Notre yeah and can you say a
little bit about how exactly arrived T
the first fine card was was edited
without music there was no temp and so I
received basically a long rough cut of
the film we had talked a little bit
about mood Danny wanted music that was
physical that that had had a kind of a
visceral quality and music that you've
that you felt in your body that affected
the body as much as the emotions
I decided to use the other helicopters
and so almost as a part of the music so
very much to wrote around around those
sounds which were obviously going to be
dominant and not seen and and I tried a
couple of different approaches were all
quite different but this one was really
the standout for me and and luckily he
agreed
I think this scene really set set the
tone for the rest of the score and kind
of became almost like a blueprint for
for the rest of the music and when you
say the other versions were very
different how different were they they
weren't as violent they weren't as as
sort of aggressive they were definitely
focusing on another kind of mood which
which yeah I mean in hindsight is was
completely wrong of course you know but
fairly soft string kind of sort of
clouds of string harmonies not unlike
the stuff we were doing on prisoners for
example and with the workhead different
or easier because of prisoners because
you had that relationship
the score is quite different from
prisoners but definitely we had sort of
established a relationship and a way of
working which which served us well you
know going into into Sicario and now
we're we're on our third film together
then he really challenges me I think he
really expects me to to come up with
something that he hasn't heard before
that that is that is something that
surprises him and that you know has a
strong character and has individuality
to it and and and I really I really like
that I really really enjoy that that
challenge so he doesn't come to you and
say hey I like the music in this film no
it's more about sort of mood and
atmosphere and themes and we talked
about a certain sense of melancholy as
well kind of the the melancholy of the
desert the melancholy of the border area
as he has said it the the sadness of
Mexico some some way and and and that
there are there elements of that
definitely this and I think the
geography the landscape is is important
as well and the landscape is almost like
a character and was very inspiring from
he's gonna move to Alvin what stage did
you know you're working on the film did
alejandro send you the script I came
very late into the movie would you
sakamoto was basically the main composer
and he was very sick before and he
recovered and as he recovered he started
accepting one movie what was a Japanese
movie from a very classic old direct
wrong and then I think he cut very fast
afterwards offer from in El grito we
could not refuse so he had like in a way
he know it was a bit kind of clashing
and as well you still was quite weak and
the meds I think in summer in Tokyo and
he was telling me this and I thought
like it's a bit crazy after such a long
process of recovery but he told me
already that there's a lot of music
inside like like licensed music in the
way I mean I was kind of in in the movie
and then in September I got two calls
that ok can you come tomorrow and that
said no maybe on Monday and then
basically I was arriving and so much
work and I smelled so much energy and it
was an incredible process because it's
the first time I ever did the score was
great to work with I hunt well basically
I had to say it sounds like he had an
idea of what he wanted from you
they had very specific ideas and we
always had this incredible long meetings
yeah I think one meeting we had was like
eight hours Wow
what were you talking about for a hour
basically we went the whole movie
through like we really from the
beginning today and talking about
exactly what you want but of course you
can't describe music but you don't know
exactly
maybe somebody says you have on
something very fragile emotional you do
it and say I was actually too little
emotional I mean more and more
so so I got like 12 pages in the end
like the only description and then of
course when you start working and you
try to remember what you talked about
it's more raw or you're defining
something like a feeling right and I
think that part worked very well because
we've been thinking about the same thing
and then from this point on it became
very easy
for me this dream scenes basically they
where he has this kind of surrealistic
moments but the scenes became kind of
very important because everybody who
reads about the movie knows how the
story will end it's quite linear in a
way so for me that church scene
specifically and as well the other
dreams became quite what kind of metal
metaphoric level and of course the
church scene was a important scene for
me because it's basically where they
both meet again in Italy in the Sun and
it's quite emotional scene in the
beginning though there was no music and
in this in that scene and and I always
wanted to mark them that you see that
you're realizing you're in a different
state so I tried to create a kind of
reckon recognizable little iconic sounds
I used some of the recording which was
recording earlier some muted piano notes
for both what he was improvising on the
piano
and then I took them and build from that
part very detailed very small let's say
almost unrecognizable sounds a lot of
the scenes where thing there's no music
there is actually a lot of music because
the way we composed sometimes was very
fractured or very detailed or very let's
say they would not work as a as a single
piece along with the other movie has
been very spark sometimes and very
gentle of course and how much time we
given to write your school's writing was
was probably from like October until
around this time really we recorded I
think early February and yeah I mixed
end of end of February but I'd read the
script many months before and went to
the set
in New Mexico where they were shooting
and so it was brewing in the in the
subconscious for a for a for a while
before that and how long the way you
give him from the start because they
flew me into LA I was basically working
like seven weeks in row then other
hundred City I think we done we can
leave now then a few queues came and I
went back to Berlin thank you thank you
very for coming
it was a great pleasure to have you I
was very straight up about that like
that no one from within their
organization could have creative
approval because that's no way for
filmmakers to be able to make a film
like this I was just very straight up
and I actually think people aren't used
to people being honest and being
straight up in our business and actually
I think it works and what was their
opinion when they saw the finished
product
both Mullins family and the estate of
you know absolutely delighted with the
film
you